scientists have recreated near-death  brains in a dish we always wonder how  our brains are different from our  ancestor and genome sequencing can give  us some idea indeed there are 61 genes  which are different between human and  neanderthal one such gene is the splice  variant regulator nova 1  now in modern human there is a specific  mutation which makes it different from  the archaic version scientists wanted to  understand how the archaic version can  change the brain architecture and that's  why they recreated the archaic version  using crispr cas9  once they have developed organoids from  both these  versions they found out the  organoids containing archaic version of  nova 1 has differences in firing pattern  molecular differences and morphological  differences and that's how they  recreated evolution in a dish  subscribe for more see you in next video